Today is a good day, Fellow Scholars. Why is
that? Because we are going to talk about this,
this and this, three incredible new papers
that will help you unleash your creativity
like never before. And a word about Google
DeepMind’s Gemini AI at the end of the video.
First, let’s try to become a virtual film
director, and create videos. But wait,
one of our previous episodes was exactly on
that. Yes…but here, you get to be a director,
but not in the way you think. So, how? Well,
first, let’s start with a photograph. Now
get this, Google’s earlier AI helps us to
fly into this photo. This is incredible,
it even supports curved camera motions, and
long-term videos. However, there is a problem.
What is the problem? Long-term coherence is
not the greatest. The scene seems to deviate
further and further away from the origin photo,
of course, because it has to make up a lot of
stuff. There is a follow up paper on this, this is
better, but the issues still remain the same. But,
we learned something important here.
Whatever the new solution is going to
look like, now we know that we should be
evaluating it on quality and coherence.
Now let’s have a look at a new text to video
technique. It promises zero shot scene generation.
This is incredible. What is that? It means that
it is able to generate scenes with these prompts,
kind of like an artist painting a landscape
that they have never seen before. It did not
have access to similar videos in its training
data, and yet, here it is. I love it. And,
back to quality and coherence: in my
opinion, we have higher-quality results,
and coherence is really good too. All we
need is just a piece of text input. So,
how? How is this even possible?
Well, I will tell you in a moment.
Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Now let’s compare it to previous techniques,
this is against Runway’s GEN-1. We showcased
this in an earlier video too. Hmm, do you see what
I see here? Yes, it is not your eyes, the output
seems a little slower, GEN-1 indeed generates a
few duplicate frames. Otherwise, not bad. This
is a tool that is already being used out there to
create movie projects. Not feature length movies,
but do not let that fool you. AI film festivals
are already being held where people put together
videos of 1-10 minutes in length. Not 5-second
videos anymore. Prizes are also given out,
and if that fires you up, you can do submit your
own work too. Everybody can become an artist and
take part in this. What an incredible time to be
alive, right. So that was GEN-1. I will note that
GEN-2 also exists, to the best of my knowledge,
without a paper. Now, let’s compare GEN-1 to the
new technique…and the new technique, wow, this is
an incredible jump in just one paper. And GEN-1
appeared not years ago, but less than a year ago.
Such improvement in less than one year. And as
always, just imagine what we will be capable of
just two more papers down the line. My goodness.
But, we are not done yet. Not even close!
Now hold on to your papers Fellow Scholars,
and let’s see how it performs against
another technique from this year. And for me,
this is once again, wow. Really, this kind of
improvement in just one paper is very impressive.
Now, look here, because this is super important.
What is this? Well, Fellow Scholars, this is the
mesh representation of the scene. Digital
3D geometry. And I hear you asking, great,
now we can put it into our video games, that is
important, but Károly, is that super important?
Yes it is. You see, meshes are essential
in understanding this work. And here comes
one of my favorite things about this paper.
First, it starts out with a mesh structure,
digital geometry, and over time, this AI
is like a sculptor who is working on a clay
model. Yes, as the camera moves around,
it “grows” this mesh outwards. Loving it!
Now, this was text to video. And
also, text to 3D geometry. But now,
wait a second. Text prompts are great, but what
if we already have an image of our scene instead,
but that’s just a 2D image, and we would like 3D
geometry instead? Well, have a look at this paper.
Oh yeah! It promises that it takes just this
one image, and it guesses what is around it,
what is behind it, in a coherent manner.
Well, it promises that. But, I will believe
it when I see it. Whoa, look at that! It’s not
perfect by any means, but it is real good. And
“good” is an important keyword. Why? Well,
take it from the legendary chip engineer,
Jim Keller. That was an incredibly good summary
of what you see here. And a huge honor. Thank you.
So, yes if it’s good, two more papers down the
line and it will be great. So we can now create
these videos from text, or a photograph. But
get this, you might not even need a photograph
to perform all this. Yes, that’s right. With
the third paper for today, you can even have
a photo that is almost completely destroyed, and
it will be able to restore it really well. This
can then go into the photo to 3D techniques. Can
you imagine before watching Two Minute Papers,
that someone says that from this
photo, and two AI research papers,
and it will be restored with amazingly high
quality, and then, you can even put it into
a video game. No one would have believed it. And
yet, here we are. Wow. Now note that of course,
image inpainting techniques already exist,
there are heaps and heaps of papers on it,
for instance, here is a legendary paper,
PatchMatch from 14 years ago. All handcrafted,
human ingenuity. A graphics paper, of
course. That was really impressive. But
compared to what we can do today. Wow. I
am out of words. What a time to be alive!
Now as promised, a word about Gemini. We
discussed it in detail a few videos ago,
and I made sure that we mainly discuss results
not from the marketing materials, but from the
research paper itself. We are Fellow Scholars
here, and paper results are more detailed,
and easier to verify. However, while I was
talking, I also showed you some materials
like this. In the meantime, Google discussed
how this footage was made. And it was made not
with the AI-s real-time feedback on a video, but
they used still images from the video plus wrote
a prompt to give it to the AI. The answers were
then showed here. These prompts range from simple,
like what do you see here to something
more detailed. However, we did not see
these prompts. I think the best would have been
if it were presented in a way like you see here,
and second best would have been adding a
disclaimer to the footage that still images
and additional prompting was used. The paper
results that span the majority of our videos are
to the best of my knowledge, accurate. I wanted to
make really sure to revisit this just to make sure
that you always get accurate information about
these works. That is The Way of The Scholar.